we're back we're back we're back and
we're matching yes we are I actually
have almost the same jacket as that I
love it yeah people aren't shouldn't be
wearing fur anymore we wear teddy bears
because that's less violent okay so
everyone keeps mentioning the teddy bear
just so you know your velvet friend over
there told me like basically congrats
for killing a teddy bear for the coke
velvet pink velvet oh
I over there is funny that's a Dick's
jacket by the way yeah oh that's a what
that's a Dick's jacket I heard yeah hmm
no it's okay okay I can't say anything I
took a bunch of stuff home I was gonna
ask Kenzie boots and the Kenzie jeans
and those like you know yeah the basic
tops and stuff I've worn a lot of that
this week
those are your clothes I put the holes
in those jeans
paid the most on the last day of set
I thought I thought so
okay you know what's funny is that knew
it I really honest to God thought that I
would be the one to be a complete mess
and I had my moments but it just didn't
happen like on the actual last day first
of all we've been this is the way I
compare it to is that if everybody is a
light switch Yeah writers crew members
cast
every day in the last week somebody got
wrapped so it didn't all happen at once
right so it's so that's the part that
gets me emotional is if you think about
a room full of light you start switching
it off I'm getting emotional slowly
until that last person gets wrapped and
then lights are off you know why would
you I know I'm sorry but it just yeah I
don't want to cry yeah that's that's
kind of how I compared it to you know
because in order for this show to shine
as bright as it did you needed to have
all those lights on and like I said it's
not just the cast that's just the stuff
you see in front of the camera like on
your TV but there is such a large family
of people that make that happen
um you know and I I have I'm interested
in sort of maybe producing my own stuff
at some point and I'm starting to enter
that world and I'm seeing how much work
goes into that and how many you know
proficient people and skilled people are
required to make the smallest thing
happen yeah let alone a show like ours
which is like an action movie in 43
minutes yes so
yeah I'm Blown Away by how lucky we were
to have the crew and cast that we've had
for 14 years and we've retained about
what 37 original crew members which is
like unheard of wow in 14 years yeah and
those that moved on either retired or
they went on to like move to higher up
positions on other shows like you know
it's pretty impressive very impressive
yeah what has the show meant to you
I mean this show has literally I mean on
a more
uh personal note it's obviously put me
on the map professionally for anybody
who didn't know who I was because this
was my first real job here in the US
um and then obviously I mean I started
my family on this show I met my husband
through the show I I you know a lot of
the people that are here went to my
wedding and I had my children on the
show my son was born in season five my
daughter was born in season eight so
cool you know
um so yeah I bought my first house
because of the show do you know what I
mean like it's just life started for me
on this show
um yeah and I have to thank my parents
for being supportive being like I want
to go to America to New York and they're
like go we have your back go and I was
like thank you Mom and Dad so yeah it
takes a village right not just to raise
a child it takes a village to like be a
full human to be a full adult yeah you
Mom and Dad yes yes and lastly working
with LL we've been trying to get the tea
on his album he gave us a little tea but
what was that like because he is also
very iconic you think Oh I thought you
meant in regards to his album I was like
I don't know anything about it I just
know that yeah I he no
um what was it like working with him
well here's the funny thing is that
growing up
um I used to go to Blockbuster yes and
and ask for the posters the movie
posters that they'd taken down because I
wanted to line my room with movie
posters because this is I've always
wanted to be in this business
and it just so happens that one of the
posters in my room was The Bachelor with
Chris O'Donnell's big old face right
there staring at me and so you know to
me that was that was like the oh my gosh
moment it's Chris O'Donnell that person
that was like on my wall yeah
um I have to confess that I I wasn't as
Savvy about Todd before I started the
show
um but it's a fact I grew up in Portugal
and a little fisherman town in Portugal
that's lovely and very touristy now but
at the time it was a little fisherman
down and so
um but when I I mean you asked about
Todd when he walks in the room I mean
when he walks in the room
that man is like his Aura just Sparkles
like he's just a uh and it matches his
personality like he is one of the most
wonderful humans I've ever met I mean
he's so incredibly intellectual like you
see that guy waving his hands around
wearing his like sparkly shiny silver
suit when he was getting his you know
Hall of Fame stuff going on but the but
the man the man on the inside like I say
that that's Batman but Bruce Wayne
is an intellectual like
um in his own description introverted if
you can even believe that yeah reads A
Lot studies a lot like he's an
incredibly well-rounded human it is the
end of NCIS last day on set who cried
the most Chris oh yeah Chris had a great
Oprah speech good tears
um cathartic tears yeah I mean we all
cry you cry I I mean I cry all the time
you do yeah
I think that vulnerability is the new
Strength yes
yeah what kind of cry are you giving
like an actor cry like you know you're
crying and you want to look good while
you're doing it or is it a straight up
ugly cry are you saying like am I doing
like give me an example of an actor cry
versus like a regular is does he give
actor cries or real cries what is it
like she asked me who cried on said the
most the last day I was like Chris
O'Donnell oh my God I was yes I was
surprised I thought it would be me and
no Chris was by far the person who was
like most openly emotional yeah okay for
sure Oprah oh my
God he was he's getting it like Homeland
cry yeah okay okay no but I mean I think
that
if you laugh and you cry you do so
because you're paying attention and so I
think if you're paying attention you got
to feel both sides of that I you know
what you just hit it with this
did you take anything from set either I
stole so much I knew it I knew it this
jacket I wear in the finale
stop and I was cold and I was like what
am I going to wear am I going to wear a
furry coat am I going to kill a teddy
bear and put it on and am I gonna wear
this velvet and so I put on the Velvet
there's been no complaints so far about
development no teddy bears were killed
in the making of this jacket okay I
stole the weight set from the gym oh
yeah it's in the back of my truck right
now
we're gonna go we're gonna go pump some
some iron right now we're gonna hit the
buys and tries we're gonna blast the
glutes it's gonna get real insane it's
insane what is the show meant to you
I mean it would be faster to say what it
hasn't meant to me
um it's 14 years of my life that's one
third of my life
um it's you know four thousand nine
hundred and seventy four days
um I started the show I wasn't married I
didn't have kids like the opportunity to
work with people that I love on a
regular basis come home to my family to
wake up and you know sometimes be able
to take my kids to school like that
doesn't happen and I'm not I prior to
the show I was traveling and doing
movies everywhere and my kids have only
known this version of life which is me
being able to make it to soccer games
which is not soccer games but swimming
and
um and it's been amazing yeah yeah is
there a chance we can see your character
on another NCIS someday
um
I mean that is um
that is always a possibility
there is a NCIS uh Winnipeg coming it's
very cold lots of layers isn't this ET
Canada yeah
why are you playing with me like this
there's always an opportunity to bring
back a character in that Universe okay
foreign